[Applause]
[Music]
we might not notice it that the weld is
changing really really fast
[Music]
biotechnology robotics nanotechnology
every day somewhere on earth some
discovery is being made discoveries that
will make our lives longer more
comfortable and generally just much
better we could almost say the viewer
that we are onboard a high-speed train
bound for a future
they're already companies in existence
today which look like they could have
come straight out of a science fiction
movie would you like some examples well
then are you familiar with organovo it's
a truly incredible company it's listed
on the NASDAQ and its business is no
less than the bio printing of tissues to
implant into the human body and thus
eliminating the need for organ
transplants can you imagine printing a
liver it's truly remarkable stuff
and what about the company modern meadow
this startups aim is to produce leather
and meat without having to kill any
animals they want to produce their own
steaks in a lab and then take them to
the supermarket the question is though
would you eat it and how about another
example never heard of Illumina it's the
largest company dedicated to DNA
sequencing in the world among other
targets they are trying to detect cancer
before any of the symptoms appear it's
almost unbelievable isn't it
well these are only three of hundreds of
companies which are literally building
the future today but you know what
Morgan Briggs Inc DNA sequencing that's
not really the best part the best part
is the end of poverty is getting closer
every day and the reality is that it's
already right around the corner and
listen we're not just talking about
extreme poverty here on the contrary
current realities like hunger or not
being able to eat nice or not having
access to healthcare or even not being
able to go on holiday aren't going to be
rare and very infrequent in the near
future and buying near future we mean
this is going to be a reality in
probably just a few years
alright alright so now for me you must
be thinking so I'm in finally lost it
it's all down here for visual politic
from here well no actually I haven't
lost my mind in fact here with all of
you as witnesses I am willing to bet you
that in the next year we will experience
the best period of prosperity in the
history of mankind and I'm certainly not
the only one who shares this opinion
listen to what Warren Buffett the
investment genius has to say about it
or how about the rock Obama as well if
you had a choice of when to be born and
you didn't know ahead of time who you
were going to be what nationality
whether you were male or female what
religion but you said when in human
history would be the best time to be
born the time would be now well I'm here
to tell you even more this wave of
prosperity will bring opportunities
we've never even thought of before all
right all right but for the skeptics
here are the numbers
[Music]
it is estimated that by the end of 2016
3.2 billion people are already going to
be in the middle class and each year
more than 140 million people will make
it into this select Club it is as if
every year a group of people the size of
the population of Mexico are leaving
poverty behind notice that this process
is accelerating and it's expected that
by 2020 that's just three years from the
time of this video coming out that most
of the world's population will belong to
the middle class this greater the middle
class will mean that the poor will
finally be in the minority
[Music]
Plus before I continue I am sure you
might be wondering how exactly do you
define middle class since income levels
vary from country to country when we
talk about middle-class what we're
talking about is people who can afford
to have a varied diet people who can
face and cover unexpected expenses as
well as education and people who can buy
an automobile these people they might
not be rich but they definitely aren't
poor anymore and this is a brand new
thing in the history of mankind
[Music]
so now that you have an idea of how
things are changing today let's have a
look at the historical perspective when
the Polian was fighting everyone in
Europe only two million people could be
considered middle class that is less
than half of the population of Singapore
today a pretty tough situation for the
vast majority of people who were living
at that time well since then 150 years
have passed but it wasn't until the
1970s that the number of people in the
middle class passed the 1 billion people
mark
[Music]
today the number is about three billion
and by 2021 it's expected to reach four
billion and as I mentioned of the
process it's getting faster and faster
every single day and this new middle
class they're going to make an
impressive entrance so believe me and as
we had these billions of people emerging
into a global middle class they need to
be said they need to be housed they need
power they need transport they want to
they want to travel when see the world
so there are tremendous opportunities
for an expansion of economic activity to
meet their needs
[Music]
yes sir city you're looking at right now
is Hanoi which is the capital of Vietnam
the country in the world where
capitalism is actually most liked that's
according to a recent study from the Pew
Research Center
[Music]
seems like we in the West might have
some catching up to do
in fact the majority of this new middle
class they're coming from Asia
[Music]
almost nine out of every ten new people
who make it in the middle class live in
Asia the continent of the economic booms
and the growing epicenter of power on
earth you just have to take a look at
countries like the Philippines or
Thailand in just a few years these
countries middle classes will be as big
as those in the UK France and Italy yes
they will remain poorer countries but
the growth of the middle class is still
very impressive but do you want to know
how things are really changing well this
is Jakarta
[Music]
I'm singable that means for the
companies that that's something we're
going to get into later but out of all
these countries one is making a
particularly big difference and that's
China whose middle class has absolutely
exploded
according to estimations by McKinsey
analysts say it's in five years this
amount of people where to create say the
Chinese Republic of middle class
citizens this country would be the third
most populated country in the world not
bad eh so if you want to know what these
changes really mean take a look at
Chongqing the most populated city in
China
this isn't the growth of the middle
class these people now have money
available to buy all kinds of products
clothing electronics cars and of course
travel and now you can probably
understand why the countries in Asia
especially China are so important for
multinational companies kind of largest
online ride hailing platform dd2 thing
says it's received 1 billion US dollars
from US tech giant Apple pay close
attention to this data because it's
probably interesting if you're starting
a business it is estimated that the
spending growth of the Chinese in the
next four years alone will exceed what
the British or German spend so if you
are visual politic friends at a company
you might want to think about
investigating the Asian market because
many opportunities will appear in the
next few years
[Music]
the consequences of this I'm just an
opportunity to make money and do more
business probably the most important
consequence of this middle class
expansion is that we will live in a
happier world let me explain you've
probably heard the phrase money doesn't
make you happy
well actually according to recent
research this is not entirely true in
2010 Angus Deaton and Daniel Kahneman
both winners of the Nobel Prize in
Economics presented a paper which proved
that up to the figure of $75,000 a year
happiness and income were very closely
related meaning more income equals more
happiness up to $75,000 a year I mean
this makes sense with more money you
don't have to worry about making it to
the end of the month paying your bills
and not having enough to eat as well as
not being a mistake family to the doctor
and Mick cetera etc so according to
these two academics the expansion of the
middle class is leading to a happier
world but wait just a minute because
there is more more middle class means
more educated people
this means more researchers and more
entrepreneurs more ideas more innovation
than therefore more progress well today
in China there are more college students
than in the United States
remember the companies that we saw at
the beginning of this video well soon
enough there are going to be plenty more
of those now you may be wondering is
this all really as wonderful as we're
describing a visual politic how come
people such as Donald Trump and lepen
are so popular that well this
middle-class boom is not happening in
all parts of the world therefore it's
really important we understand that if
Western economies aren't working
perfectly are having problems they
should take responsibility for it and
stop blaming it on other countries there
are plenty of opportunities in the
global economy and now is the time to
adapt and seize them but now I can
probably guess what your thinking is all
of this growth really sustainable ways
all of this progress and development
destroy the environments or caused other
such problems well that's not exactly
clear
[Music]
now it is true that in theory more
middle-class means more spending and
therefore more consumerism and more
pressure on natural resources etc but
there are some things to consider first
more middle-class also means more people
in big cities and the consumerism here
is usually more sustainable transport is
the most evident example while public
transport is frequent in large cities it
is rare in small places more
middle-class also means faster
demographic transition so more women
study and work and so the population
tends to shrink as well and above all
more middle-class means as we said for
more ideas and more innovation and among
these things are often ideas which allow
more sustainable consumerism so however
we want to approach this situation then
although there is certainly a lot of
room for advancement and improvement we
think that this really is a time in
history and we should all be feeling
rather positive so that's our opinion
here at visual politic and now we would
like to know what you think do you
believe we are moving towards a better
world do you think that Asia can be a
land of opportunity for businesses well
do let us know in the comments below
we would love to hear your thoughts and
if you enjoyed this video please do hit
that thumbs up button below and don't
forget to subscribe for brand new videos
every Monday and every Thursday and as
always I'll see you in the next video
[Music]